you love getting on the social media and
and participating but you posted a
picture that upset a lot of people
because they thought it was real this
was okay so you showed I think what
looked like you would had an accident
we're missing a finger yeah and this was
actually because of a roll yeah right
it's become because of a movie I posted
that photo I said look what just
happened
believe it or not it doesn't hurt as bad
as you would think obviously I thought
people would write think it's for a
movie but everyone's comments like oh my
god I am so sorry
that's yeah people thought people were
horrified and people thought oh my god
this is terrible poor Aaron Paul yeah at
that point if I were you I'd have just
chopped the finger off I had to go back
in and edit my my comment and I put a
little you know film emoji and and then
people knew his work oh we're people mad
did some people get mad because
sometimes when they show when someone
gives you a lot of empathy and then you
go yeah I was just kidding thank you
there can be yeah I don't maybe they did
but I don't know
I hope yeah yeah yeah well I was furious
you